I think the unprecedented indictment of
a former president of the United States
for a campaign Finance issue is an
outrage
and I think it's it's clear to the
overwhelming majority of the American
people that this is nothing short of a
of a political prosecution
being affected by uh a Manhattan D.A who
literally campaigned
on bringing charges against one
particular American
and I must tell you that uh that that
should be offensive to every American
left right and Center every American
deserves
equal treatment under the law and I
believe the American people will see
this for what it is
but to your point the answer
the answer is not to become like them
the answer is to return to a commitment
to the foundations of the rule of law
enshrined in the Constitution of the
United States
and the antidote to that ultimately is
you know Vince Lombardi said sometimes
there's no substitute for just going out
and winning the ball game
right and I really do believe
that whether it's local prosecutors
racist or the highest office in the land
we we've got to Rally behind men and
women that are committed to the
principles at the heart of our Republic
that are committed to equal justice
before the law and to a fair
Administration